I'm back from vacation we're here to
break down the democratic race just in a
mashes GOP exit in border politics so
much to talk about i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show so the vacation
was great thanks for asking also I will
explain to you III do have to note
really quick off the top I definitely
picked the right week to leave
California so that was great
I left right during the earthquakes
coordinated with God God and I are like
this guy's I mean and it was just it was
great so now we're back and we gotta
jump in so let's jump into the news here
is the news Joe Biden is dropping like a
stone in pulses are all over the place a
little bit with regard to who is
currently in second place basically it
is Joe Biden still at the top and then
there is a bunching of Elizabeth Warren
and Bernie Sanders and Kamala Harris all
of whom are within basically a
percentage point according to the Real
Clear Politics average but Biden has
dropped precipitously from a month ago a
month ago he was up in the mid 30s close
to 40 percent according to most of the
polls and in every single poll now he is
dropping below 30 percent except for a
hill poll about a week old so here are
the last several polls for Joe Biden CNN
has him at 22 the hill has him at 33
Quinnipiac has him at 22 ABC has him at
30 The Economist has him at 23 okay so
he is somewhere between I think it's
safe to say somewhere between 20 and 30
and that is probably where he is he's
probably in the mid-20s somewhere by
these polls according to the Real Clear
Politics average he is currently at 26%
where it gets interesting is who's in
second place so there are a bevy of
polls that are all mixed up as to who is
in second place so according to CNN
Kamala Harris has jumped into second
place with 17% of the vote that poll was
taken pretty much directly after the
last debate she may have receded a
little bit since then the latest poll is
coming courtesy of The Economist and you
gov and that came maybe three days ago
that showed that Joe Biden was a twenty
three percent followed by Elizabeth
Warren at 19 percent which would be a
massive jump for Elizabeth Warren and
that's a big difference between that and
the hill poll which has her at 9% so a
10-point spread there followed by Kamala
Harris at 15
followed by Bernie Sanders at 9 which
would be a precipitous drop-off for
Bernie Sanders and put
basically in peat Budaj territory buddha
judges big boost still has not come so
buddha judge for all the talk about he's
raised in an enormous amount of money
and he's super talented and debate and
all of this he's cracked ten percent in
approximately one poll in the last two
months so he is not anywhere close to
the top of that feels he's really in a
solid fourth place but it's really
question as to who is second so
according to the economists elizabeth
warren is in second according to ABC
bernie sanders is still in second with
nineteen percent and according to
Quinnipiac Kamala Harris is in second
with twenty percent so we really have no
idea how the second kind of tier of the
field is doing what we do know is the
Joe Biden has been sliding and Joe Biden
has been sliding because as I have
predicting been predicting since weeks
before Joe Biden jumped into the race
his first day was going to be his best
day and the reason for that is twofold
one Joe Biden gaffes all the time he
gaffes all the time he's a bad
presidential candidate he was a bad
presidential candidate in 1988 he was a
bad presidential candidate in 2008 he is
a bad presidential candidate and he
keeps saying things that get him into
trouble that is problem number one for
him and that is a Joe Biden specific
problem if Joe Biden had discipline he
wouldn't be in that much trouble if Joe
Biden were anodyne he wouldn't be in
that much trouble if Joe Biden were
boring he wouldn't be in that much
trouble but he's not he says things on a
routine basis where he sticks his foot
so far down his own throat that it ends
up lodged in his esophagus and he has to
have a minor surgery in order to remove
it each and every time and with every
minor surgery he loses a fair amount of
political blood that is problem number
one for Joe Biden probably number two
for Joe Biden is not really a Joe Biden
problem it is a modern American politics
problem and that is Joe Biden has been
in politics for a very long time we live
in an era where the best thing to be is
a cipher the best thing to be in
American politics is somebody that
nobody knows where you stand
nobody knows what you would do nobody
knows what your record is in this way
Donald Trump really was a cipher Donald
Trump when he ran in 2016
everybody knew his personality and his
personality was outsized she was a big
TV star but nobody knew where he was
politically he had taken every position
on the map he had suggested he was for
Canadian style universal health care but
he was against Obamacare he had
suggested that he was both for gun
control and against gun control he had
suggested for
while that he was pro-choice and then he
became pro-life so he was all over the
place and nobody really knew where he
stood including me which is why I
estimated that he would probably be more
to the left than he ended up being he's
been a very conservative president in
terms of most of his policies well the
best thing to be in American politics is
a person with no record because if you
have a record
if you've said things before that means
that people can attack you on those
things and this has been where Joe Biden
is now it is also that record that means
that Americans are comfortable with him
so the strongest point for Joe Biden is
also his weakest point the fact that Joe
Biden was vice president for eight years
the fact that Joe Biden has been in the
Senate since 1732 since before the
Senate existed since Cato
right there that is both his benefit
because we are all comfortable with Joe
Biden we all come and know who Joe Biden
is it is also his detriment because it
means that he has voted for things and
that he has said things and that his
debated things he's actually had to take
positions on policy the best thing to be
is somebody who's never had to take a
position Barack Obama never had to vote
on the Iraq war because he didn't enter
the amount in the United States Senate
until 2006 and they're just too many
members of the Democratic Party race
right now who don't have a record
they've actually had to vote on things
they've gotten to vote against things
which is a nice convenient place to be
but if you're in the Senate for a long
period of time that means your name is
on legislation it means that you may
have backed things that were necessary
in 1994 aka the criminal reform bill
veek rotten the crime bill and then
those become unpopular over time maybe
it means that you've had to work with
senators we'll really nasty people as
Joe Biden did thirty years ago all of
that can be dredged up against you
whereas if you are a Kamala Harris and
you joined the United States Senate in
the last five minutes and you joined the
United States Senate at a time where you
didn't have to vote on any major policy
proposals except to say no to Donald
Trump well that means that things are
pretty convenient for you so Joe Biden
he's comfortable the American people
feel comfortable with him it's why he in
general pub in in sort of the general
polling the general election polling Joe
Biden is far and away the strongest
candidate against Donald Trump because
he has that record because people are
comfortable with him in those polls Joe
Biden is consistently running about 50%
there's not another Democrat in the
field who's running about 50% every
other Democrat is basically running dead
even with Donald Trump Joe Biden is
running like ten points
and then every other Democrat is running
within spitting distance of Donald Trump
including Camille Harris who's running
basically an even race with Donald Trump
at this point which you would assume
means that Trump wins because this will
be the point where people are most
positive about Kamala Harris not the
point at which they're most negative
about Kamala Harris so the best
candidate for Democrats in a general
election is precisely the candidate who
is also most vulnerable in a primary and
we're gonna get to Joe Biden's
bifurcated candidacy and why in a
general election he'd look good right
now
but in a primary he looks really bad
right now why you'd want to sell Joe
Biden if you're in the Joe Biden stock
market during the presidential stock
market we'll get to that in just a
second first I'm a huge baseball fan you
know we got nut about baseball I'm a
huge baseball fan in fact I even wrote a
book with my dad
about the Chicago White Sox winning the
World Series I know for all seven White
Sox fans baseball is the best and in
baseball like in any sport there is
nothing as exciting as a fantastic
rivalry in fact the White Sox and the
Cubs played over the weekend my White
Sox split with the Cubs in the total
series 62 60 White Sox but there is a
new show a new podcast is from wondering
and it's called Sports Wars this is
truly awesome it tells the stories of
some of the greatest sports rivalries of
all time they've got Brett Favre versus
Aaron Rodgers Rafael Nadal and Roger
Federer which is one of my favorite
sports rivalries and adult dominates
Federer head to head but Federer is the
better overall player former NBA stars
like Isaiah Thomas and Michael Jordan
Michael Jordan basically militated to
keep Isiah Thomas off the dream team
even teammates like Shaq and Kobe will
have to see if LeBron and Anthony Davis
develop that sort of rivalry their
upcoming series over at one driana
college football rivalries will cover
Oklahoma versus Texas and Georgia versus
Florida the rivalries get pretty wild
and insane listen to sports Wars right
now on Apple podcast Spotify or wherever
you're listening right now again go
check out sport's worth it really is
awesome it's a fun break from politics
and it's informative and cool go check
it out
Sports Wars on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you're listening right now okay
so Joe Biden's candidacy for a general
election looks good for a primary it
looks really bad so here is general
election Joe Biden and this is exactly
the sort of stuff he will be attacked on
in a primary so joe biden was asked
about decriminalizing border crossing
the democratic party in this primary is
running headlong for a cliff they're
embracing every Farr
left position they can get their hands
on it's truly incredible in the last
debate
virtually every Democrat pledged to
decriminalize border crossing now what
would that do it would actually
encourage people to cross the border
illegally not at ports of entry it is
not illegal to cross the American border
at a port of entry and claim asylum you
do not have to be an illegal immigrant
it is illegal to claim asylum falsely
but if you walk across a border port of
entry and then you claim asylum not only
is that not illegal it is purely legal
and you could be given citizenship on
the basis of your asylum claim what is
illegal is to try and swim the Rio
Grande we don't want people doing that
because it's very dangerous we don't
want people doing that because we do not
have proper policing along our 2,000
mile border with Mexico but every
Democrat except for Joe Biden now has
basically come out and said they want to
decriminalize border crossing now what
would that mean it would mean that when
you pick people up and they claim asylum
instead of you being able to detain them
for illegally crossing the border you
would be forced to catch and release
them pretty much immediately you pretty
much be forced to allow them to be
released into the general population
into the United States instead of being
deported for the simple crime of
crossing the border illegally they would
make it the same as crossing a border
points of entry now if you want more
dead people floating down the Rio Grande
it makes perfect sense you want more
people crossing that desert and trying
to cross through an area that is
unguarded because if they are ever
caught in the United States they can say
listen I didn't my entry wasn't illegal
so now I'm claiming asylum and I can
live here for years and years and years
that is bad policy Joe Biden knows it's
bad policy he says it's bad policy this
is why in a general election he'd be
much more dangerous to President Trump
than any of the other Democrats it's
also why the Democrats will slaughter
him over the sort of stuff people who
are running close to you now who are
saying decriminalize coming in to the
country illegally do you believe that
even decriminalized no I don't know I
don't I think people should have to get
in line but if and people are coming
because they're actually seeking asylum
they should have a chance to make their
case I would be surging as we did in
Barack and I do
surging folks to the border to make
those concrete decisions okay this is
the correct answer in a general election
it is the wrong answer in primary here's
enough
here's Joe Biden talking about keeping
your health insurance so in a general
election this is obviously necessary
suggesting to 177 million Americans
they're going to lose their private
health insurance as Kamala Harris has
now done and then undone and then done
and then undone and then done right she
switched her position on this no less
than five times in the past three weeks
Joe Biden's been consistent he says
listen you're gonna get to keep your
insurance maybe we'll have a public
option which would be a bad idea but
this is a palatable pitch to Americans
if you think the Donald Trump can't run
on the Democrats wants to take away our
health insurance you're out of your mind
there's a strong general election pitch
from Joe Biden it is not strong enough
for the Democratic primary here's Joe
Biden we're in a situation where if you
provide an option for anybody who in
fact wants to buy into Medicare for all
they can buy in they buy in and they can
do it but if they like their employer
and based insurance which a lot of
unions broke their neck to get a lot of
people like their they shouldn't have to
give it up the flip of that is if you
don't go my way
you had and you go their way you have to
give up all that and what's gonna happen
when you have 300 million people landing
on a health care plan how long is that
going to take what's it gonna do okay
exactly right exactly right I've found
myself a Joe Biden defender in this
Democratic primary simply because all
the other Democrats are out of their
damned minds and it's why Joe Biden
would do well in a general election but
this is not going to avail him at all
because he is at war with the heart and
soul of his party this is how you end up
with Joe Biden and Nancy Pelosi is the
new Morrison Democratic Party that's how
crazy these folks have gone here is Joe
Biden going after Alexandra Ocasio
cortes suggesting that she is too
radical for the party which of course
she is by the way I will mention here a
Oh see my goodness that is a person who
does not know anything about anything
I mean really does not know listen it's
my first day back it's obligatory that I
mention AOC but in this context she
really messed her pants over the weekend
I mean she president Trump apparently
referred to her as Evita perón in a new
book that's set to go on sale in
mid-july he compared her to Eva Peron
okay and Ocasio Cortes then took that
comparison as a compliment
okay then she then tweeted out a quote
from Eva Peron hey he and
she tweeted out a quote from Evita perón
I know that like every woman of the
people I have more strength than I
appear to have there's only one problem
Eva Peron was a Nazi sympathizer who
seized a Jewish property in exchange for
Nazis being able to settle in Argentina
and help destroy the Argentine economy
but sure I mean I guess that's a Oh see
if IOC wants it God she is so she's so
stupid so so when Joe Biden attacks aoc
or when Nancy Pelosi attacks aoc it is
perfectly fitting unfortunately for them
that is not gonna play in the democratic
party primaries okay we'll get to that
in just one second first let me tell you
something when I love an advertiser's
product so much that actually got my buy
one myself as a gif from one of my
relatives that means that I really love
it that is the case with helix sleep
mattresses I will tell you this I went
on vacation I slept alright
I came back home last night got on that
helix sleep mattress I was out like a
light
because helix sleep mattresses are the
best they have a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete they match your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you no matter how
you sleep on your side on your back hot
sleeper whatever hulex can make what
your body needs just go to helix sleep
calm slash Ben take their two-minute
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life and for
couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and fuel
preferences for each side they have a 10
year warranty you get to try it out for
a hundred nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but that's not gonna happen you're gonna
love the mattress he looks is offering
up to 125 bucks off all mattress orders
for our listeners get up to 125 bucks
off right now at helix sleep calm / Ben
that's helix sleep calm / Ben for up to
125 bucks off your mattress order helix
sleep calm / Ben once more helix sleep
calm / man and get up to 125 bucks off
your mattress order to go check it out
right now
okay so Biden goes after AOC and he
suggests that AOC is too radical for the
party and basically she want a primary
which of course is exactly right how do
you convince the party that these more
advanced ideas are all in on Medicare
for all that my matter can advance I
would Miller in the party well by the
way watch that's what this election is
about I'm really I'm happy to debate
that issue and all those issues with my
friends because guess what again
look who won the races look who won last
time out
we had and by the way I think I think
Acacio Cortez is a brilliant bright
woman but she won a primary that in the
general election fights who won
okay so Joe Biden is correct about
everything there except her being a
brilliant bright woman that that of
course is wildly untrue but Biden knows
that he's not allowed to just say the
truth which is she's embarrassing to
every Democrat who has two brain cells
to rub together finally Biden is getting
frustrated so Biden is getting
frustrated because he understands he's
the best general election candidate and
so he's basically threatening other
Democrats listen guys you're coming
after me I could roast you I could roast
you alive now
this sort of aggressive language would
play well in a general against Donald
Trump who's also very aggressive in a
primary it looks as though he's a bully
it's so easy to go back and go back 30
40 50 years and take a context and take
it completely out of context and I mean
you know I I get all this information
about other people's past and what
they've done and not done and you know
I'm just not gonna go there if we keep
doing that
that's I mean what was she debating what
we do from here for example this whole
thing about race and busty well you know
I think if you take a look our positions
aren't any different as we're finding
out Oh senator Harris yeah she sees it
as a tool not a must in all
circumstances
yeah well look at my record okay and Joe
Biden is laughing there because he is
correct but this is the point this is
the point he had to vote on forced
busing he said no Kamala Harris has
never had to vote on the issue and so
here is the problem he's got a record
and that's what he's pointing out he
says listen I wasn't prepared for the
debate attack which is inexcusable it's
inexcusable that he wasn't prepared for
that attack considering that Senator
Cory Booker had been attacking him on
basically the same stuff the week before
but I think Biden really was unprepared
for the attack I think that Biden
thought that this was going to be
everybody treating each other decently
everybody was gonna be nice to him he
was gonna be nice to everybody
they're all gonna run against Donald
Trump and that's not the case he's been
ripped down because the same stuff that
makes him attractive in a general
election makes him a wildly unattractive
in a primary here's Joe Biden saying he
wasn't prepared for the bait attack and
that's why he's probably not gonna be
the nominee guys they're gonna come
after you sure they're gonna come at
well you prepared for them to come after
you I was prepared to come after me
wasn't prepared for the person coming at
me the way she came out she knew both
she knows me I don't know anyway I but
here's the deal
what I do know and this is a good in the
bad news the American people think they
know me and they know me okay and again
that is the the bad news for Joe Biden
and the good news for Joe Biden because
Joe Biden is going to be forced to back
away and back away and back away that
record means he's going to have to keep
backing away so for example over the
weekend he apologized for his remarks on
segregationists this is such a mistake
for him it's a mistake because his
remarks on segregationist were not Pro
segregation he said these people were
mean and they were nasty but sometimes
you have to make deals with mean nasty
people in the Senate everybody
understood that except for people who
cynically took him out of context Joe
Biden instead decided to apologize for
all of this which just opened up a new
line of attack from Democrats who said
well you know he should have apologized
for this before except racist this is
the routine now is the Joe Biden it who
was Barack Obama's VP for eight years
and the media never discovered that he
was a secret ku ku ku Klux Klan member
apparently he is he apologized for his
remarks on segregationists over the
weekend was I wrong a few weeks ago to
somehow give the impression to people
that I was praising those men who I
successfully opposed time and again yes
I was I regret it
I'm sorry afraid of the pain or
misconception they may have caused
anybody the fact that the Joe Biden is
out there apologizing he is in such
trouble and his people when I say his
people I mean his friends his allies
they are not coming to his defense and
the chief allies that matter here are
the Obamas Barack Obama has been
absolutely silent now it's not as though
Barack Obama has to endorse Joe Biden
this early in the primary season he
doesn't have to although the truth is
that very often presidents do endorse
their vice presidential candidates very
very early on but put that aside Obama
doesn't actually have to endorse him
what he does have to do as a decent
human being is come out say listen I
know Joe Biden Joe Biden is not a racist
these attacks are unfair Obama's not
doing it which is an amazing amazing
thing Michelle Obama who knows Joe Biden
she refused to come out and help Joe
Biden out so she was asked about Biden
she just basically let it go she let it
go because more important for Michelle
and Barack Obama to keep their
credentials in order with the far-left
than it is for them to defend somebody
that they know and supposedly love so
here's Michelle Obama absolutely
undercutting Joe Biden when asked about
this stuff today by the way is a
complete sentence Wow all she has to do
right there is say I like both senator
Harris and Joe Biden and I know that Joe
Biden is not a racist that's all that
she has to say
and she won't do it she won't do it the
Obamas are happy to see Joe Biden go
down and this is the problem for Joe
Biden now meanwhile the attacks on Joe
Biden are incredibly cynical now I
pointed this out after the debate
between what was effectively Joe Biden
and Camille Harris nothing else that
happened in that debate has any lasting
impact or anything that matters Kamala
Harris attacked Joe Biden on his stance
on federally mandated forced busing
which is one of the great policy fails
in modern American history she attacked
his stance on that and I said at the
time this is a cynical attack because
Camille Harris does not believe herself
in forced busing she's just doing this
to imply that Biden is a racist without
any evidence that Joe Biden is a racist
it turns out guess who was right that's
right he's got two thumbs he's getting
thumbs up right now and they're pointing
directly at that guy I was right about
this because Kamala Harris was being
incredibly cynical I'm gonna get to that
in just a second so first of all common
law Harris is trying to run as the as
the most effective candidate for black
Americans in this race very early on it
was cleared this is what her candidacy
had to be cory booker is also trying to
wrest this title from her joe biden he's
running basically even with folks like
bernie sanders and elizabeth warren
among white voters but he's running way
ahead of them among black voters Kamala
Harris is trying to carve into that lead
among black voters and what she is
finding is that she has a fairly large
problem here
Joe Biden's black vote share is still
extraordinarily high so in the latest
YouGov poll for example black voters
were split 36 to 13 between Vitus Biden
and Harris but those polls are all over
the place the Quinnipiac poll which had
by narrowly leading Harris overall also
had him narrowly leading Harris among
black voters 31 to 27% CNN had a 25 to
19% split among non white respondents
Reuters and Ipsos found that Biden's
black support had been cut in half so
Carmel Harris is trying to carve into
that by claiming alternatively that Joe
Biden is actually a secret racist and
also at the she says I'm not saying that
she's totally saying that and she's
she's lying she says I'm not saying Joe
Biden is a racist but as your
grandmother always told you whatever
happens in a sentence before but doesn't
matter when she says Joe Biden is in two
races but he keeps complimenting
segregationists and he didn't support
forced busing what she's really saying
is that secretly down deep he's got
racial animus for black folks
simultaneously Kamala Harris is trying
to pose as some sort of civil rights
warrior despite the fact that commonly
harris is not old enough to be a civil
rights warrior hey Kamala Harris is now
citing her record as being a school
child who was in an integrated and
already integrating district in Berkeley
by the way it was already well being
well integrated before Kamala Harris was
really around in Berkeley but when you
were 7 he didn't have all that much
impact on local policy as it turns out
well Kamala Harris is now likening
herself to Rosa Parks to Rosa Parks here
is what she says how khamel harris is
like Rosa Parks is beyond me
she has no record that suggests Rosa
Parks she has no record that suggests
civil rights hero nonetheless this is
her shtick black women has always been
fueled and grounded in faith and in the
beliefs of what is possible we have
always built the future that we can see
and believe in and fight for and that's
why surge owner spoke it's why may flu
it's why Rosa and Claudette set it's why
Maya wrote it's why Fanny organized
why surely brands and why I stand here
as a candidate for president of the
United States she's in the long line of
all of these people except her Barack
Obama was hardly presidents of the
United States and you know was black and
all of that Kamala Harris is just like
all of these people how I mean I guess
she's she's black too so I guess that
that's the commonality but what in her
record suggests that she is a civil
rights hero like any of the people that
she just mentioned
not a thing but that's her campaign
we'll get some more of that in just one
second first if you've ever gone
shopping for shaving products you know
that it's hard to tell which ones are
actually worth the money there are a lot
a lot of options is why Bernie Sanders
thinks there are too many deodorant
options but this is where Dollar Shave
Club helps make your life easier they
take out the guesswork and they
guarantee you quality shaving products I
know because Dollar Shave Club has all
the stuff that I need when I get ready
each morning to come into work Dollar
Shave Club has you covered head to toe
they have everything you need for
showering shaving styling your hair
brushing your teeth stay fully stocked
get what you want whenever you need it
whether that's once a month or a few
times a year as a Dollar Shave Club
member I know what I'm getting is the
highest quality because I've used all
their products they're really fantastic
no more walking through the aisle at the
store wondering what it is that I want
no more going to the store at all right
now you can put the quality of Dollar
Shave club's products to the test their
ultimate starter sets have basically
everything you need for an amazing
shower close shave or clean teeth the
best part is you can try each one for
just five bucks after that the restock
box ships regular size products at
regular prices get your ultimate starter
set for just five bucks at
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben that is
dollarshaveclub.com slash pen and get
that ultimate dollar that ultimate
starter set for just five bucks at
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben
dollarshaveclub.com slash man honestly
their products are just amazing go check
them out right now dollarshaveclub.com
slash Ben okay so Kamala Harris is
running on the dual program of Joe Biden
is a secret racist and I'm a civil
rights hero
none of those two things are true and
she is so cynical she's so manipulative
yeah I objected this on a moral level on
a real moral level what Kamala Harris is
doing to Joe Biden here is disgusting
and again I'm not a Joe Biden defender I
don't think the Joe Biden is any great
shakes as a politician I've opposed him
politically my entire career I think
that he's been wrong on ninety-eight
percent of all the things he has ever
said the only stuff he has ever said
right
is the stuff where he has pointed out
that his colleagues are too far to the
left that's it
but what Kamala Harris is doing here is
deeply cynical and gross so here as
Kamala Harris saying yesterday well you
know Biden hasn't apologized yet he
hasn't he hasn't agreed that opposing
bussing was wrong now Kamala Harris does
not does not support bussing she has the
exact same position on federally
mandated forced busing that Joe Biden
had the exact same position in fact
let's start with that clip here's Harris
saying that should consider but not
mandate busing I asked this question
after the debate and people got uptight
with me and I said it as the debate was
happening I tweeted out Kamala Harris
does not support forced busing she's
ripping and Joe Biden for not supporting
a policy that no one supports in the
United States nobody in the United
States black or white is seriously in
favor of taking children and busing them
across county lines to encourage the
quote-unquote proper racial mix of
children in particular schools no one is
in favor of that policy because it was
an enormous fail when it was tried in
the 1970s as well as the 1980s federally
mandated forced busing was one of the
most divisive and terrible pieces of
federal policy devised in the last
half-century it was a very very bad
piece of policy which is why it wasn't
supported by something like 80 percent
of Americans it led to tremendous
unintended consequences like vast
amounts of white flight outside of major
integrated cities it led to the
devastation of tax bases and led to the
starting of charter schools and private
schools and led to a less integrated
public school system overall that's what
forced busing did which is why I said if
Kamala Harris supports forced busing
let's hear a plan let's hear her make
the case well she was finally asked I
said why doesn't anyone in the media ask
her about this cuz it's obvious what
she's going to say now her spokesperson
Ian Samms originally said that she did
support federally mandated forced busing
and then Kamala Harris reversed herself
she said yeah I'd consider but I
wouldn't mandate busing which is exactly
what Joe Biden had said
when we address the issue which is a
very hard to she was a fast issue of
desegregation on America's place so I
think if busing has been in the toolbox
of what is for the goal of desegregating
she is completely full of crap when
people say things like I think that
deserves a conversation what a
politician is really saying is no I
don't think it deserves a conversation
it's not my policy when somebody says
how do you feel about X and a politician
says we should have a conversation what
the politician actually means is I don't
really want to have a conversation about
that because I don't support it but I'm
gonna give you the stop of saying that
we should have a conversation about this
Ian Sam's hey on July 4th tweeted out
she absolutely believes the federal
government was right to step in in the
60s and 70s but surely we can all agree
2019 is not 1975 ok except for the fact
that if you actually look at the racial
segregation statistics defacto not too
sure a not enforced by law but de facto
racial segregation in America's schools
today is as bad as it was during the
1980s it's in fact worse than it was
during late 1980s so what he's saying
just doesn't hold
so Kamala Harris has the exact same
position as Joe Biden the exact same
position but that didn't stop comment
Harris from attacking Joe Biden over
federally mandated busing and suggesting
the Biden his closet in closet fashion
erases for not having supported the
exact same policies she currently
opposes back in the 1970s sadly we do
not agree I've asked him and have yet to
hear him agree that busing that was
court-ordered and mandated in most
places and in that era in which I was
bust was necessary and he has yet to
agree that his position on this which
was to work with segregationist and
opposed busing was wrong period okay so
I guess her new case is that if you have
the same position in 1975 that she has
today then that means that you're a
racist in 75 but today she is not a
racist because apparently things have
progressed so far except for the fact
that if you look at the actual
integration statistics in America's
public schools they look about the same
as the
35 years ago so what she's saying right
now makes no sense I mean it makes no
sense but it is cynical and that's the
point
she's a deeply cynical politician her
attacks on Biden are really cynical but
they're gonna work because the media
refused to drill down on this they
refused to drill down and ask her
specifically the question that I am
currently asking if you say things have
radically changed since the 1970s
explain how based on the integration
statistics the de-facto integration
statistics in America's public schools
explain and then explain why federally
mandated forced busing was bad policy is
bad policy today but it wasn't bad
policy in 1978 explain nobody will ask
her that question and if they do ten
points to them I will be shocked hey
more of this in just one second we'll
get some more of common law Harris
Panzer II and then we'll get to the
other candidates who are desperately
trying to gain attention in what is
turning quickly into a two-person race
but first I'm too busy to go to the post
office the last time I went I got a
giant parking ticket because in Los
Angeles
nothing works Los Angeles is a hellhole
except for the area of the LA government
that gives parking tickets those suckers
I mean they are just so efficient no
more of this when I need to mail
something I use stamps calm because it's
fast and it's easy
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US postal office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps comm can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in the mailbox it is
that simple with stamps comm you get
five cents off every first class stamp
up to 40% off Priority Mail which is a
hell of a deal over 700,000 small
businesses including daily we're already
used stamps calm right now my listeners
get a special offer it includes a four
week trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long term commitment just go to
stamps comm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in Shapiro
that is stamps.com enter Shapiro go
check us out right now stamps.com
enter Shapiro okay so in just a second
we're gonna get to Kamala Harris's
latest proposal to drive her to the top
of the Democratic primaries shock it's a
giveaway but first we're gonna have to
go over to daily wear comm and subscribe
do it right now $9.99 a month or 99
this makes a fantastic gift right here
you see this this leftist years hot or
cold tumbler I know you've been missing
me talking about it for a week but we're
back now and it's incredible and you
could have been holding this sort of joy
to get you over the Shapiro's last week
if only you had subscribed for $99 a
year there are all sorts of wonderful
things that you get with the
subscription you get two additional
hours of the show every single day
because we are working hard once again
also you get access to daily water
backstage asking those questions being
part of my mailbag you get to be part of
the the q and a's that we do on a fairly
frequent basis here at Taylor with all
sorts of goodies that yeah yeah are some
day special on Saturdays we have a bunch
of great Sunday specials that are coming
up and really excited to share them with
you all that stuff you get when you
subscribe so $99 a year get this get the
annual subscription with the tumbler
because it is indeed terrific go check
that out right now we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so the new Democratic plan from Kamala
Harris to win her the primaries is a
giveaway so we we basically have a
giveaway competition it's a used car
salesman competition in the Democratic
Party the whole thing is a lemon but
they're gonna sell it to you as a low
low price there's a great old
politically incorrect movie with with
Kurt Russell called used cars about a
battle between two used car salesmen and
their various lots and that's what the
Democratic Party has become they're
gonna blow the bleep out of high prices
this is this is what they have become
and so Kamala Harris is going to sell
sell sell you got Bernie Sanders selling
you free college tuition and relieving
your student debt you have Elizabeth
Warren declaring that everything will be
free and now you have Kamala Harris who
is specifically making a tailored pitch
directly for black folks saying that she
wants to spend a hundred billion dollars
to increase minority homeownership
she said we must write the wrong after
generations of discrimination give black
families a real shot at homeownership
historically one of the most powerful
drivers of wealth in our country her
plan calls for a hundred billion dollars
in Housing and Urban Development grants
to provide homeowners or homebuyers who
rent or live in historically redlining
communities where minority and home and
business owners were largely blocked
from accessing capital for investment up
to a $25,000 downpayment in assistance
and closing costs so here is the problem
back in the late 1990s there was
something that we tried it was a program
in which the federal government decided
that it would help sponsor what we
called subprime mortgages these were
mortgages that went to people who did
not have a borrowing history a credit
history that would allow them to get a
loan and we made it very easy for those
folks to get federally subsidized loans
because we felt that we were trying to
right the wrongs of redlining
there is only one problem with this it
turns out that you still have to pay the
mortgage on the home so if you give
somebody a loan at a at a variable
interest rate and over time the person
is unable to pay the loan they couldn't
get the loan supposedly because of
redlining but then they got the loan and
then they defaulted over time as more
and more of those homes defaulted it
tended to provide a drag on the American
real estate market and all those loans
were collateralized because everybody
assumed that they were going to be
picked up by the federal government in
the end anyway and they were sliced and
diced
they were created into derivative
products they were sold throughout the
market and then in 2000 2008 you may
recall there was this thing that
happened where the entire world economy
crashed he was really bad I was there
you're probably there too a lot of that
was driven by terrible American housing
policy that was driven toward increasing
levels of minority homeownership now
listen I want everyone to be able to buy
a home I want everyone to be able to
afford to buy a home I own my own home I
think it is wonderful to own your own
home I do think that part of the
American Dream is being able to work
hard enough to afford to own your own
home you also have to be able to pay off
the loans if the idea is that what is
standing between home ownership and
minority communities today is redlining
well then you'd have federal lawsuits on
your hands wouldn't you I mean that's
illegal you can't do it so what exactly
is commonly Harris suggesting you she's
suggesting that redlining
is still keeping black people from
getting loans if that's the case then
she should provide the proof if that's
not the case then she should explain how
the American taxpayer ought to be on the
hook for a bunch of loans many of which
will probably go belly-up because a
$25,000 down payment in assistance and
closing costs is not going to cover a
home loan in most parts of the United
States that is not going to cover the
difference between somebody making their
loan and not making their loan
so she's proposing a cynical bill that
is again going to put the onus on the
back of the American taxpayer for loans
that are not going to be paid off those
loans will go belly-up and then the
American taxpayer will have to foot the
cost again we know this because it just
happened like five minutes ago so we're
gonna go right back to that well but
again this is part of common law
Harris's plan to steal away black
support from Joe Biden in the Democratic
primaries okay now there are a couple of
other candidates who are still in this
race Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
are still in this race according to the
Real Clear Politics polling average
Harris has moved slightly ahead of
Sanders Warren is slightly behind
Sanders but basically they are all at
parity and as I suggested the polls have
them at really weird variable leads so
according to the Economist poll
Elizabeth Warren is currently in second
just four points behind Joe Biden
according to ABC News Bernie Sanders is
in second about 11 points behind Joe
Biden according to Quinnipiac it is
Kamala Harris who is in second about two
points behind Joe Biden so it's all over
the place but it's pretty obvious that
the second tier of candidates
is Harris and Sanders and Warren so
Elizabeth Warren is trying to do the
same thing Elizabeth Warren is trying to
carve into burr in to Joe Biden's black
base of support she's gonna have way
less success because she can't play the
race card in the same way that Camilla
Harris is playing the race card against
Joe Biden to build 3.2 million new
housing units in this country and to
address the generational impact of
redlining that our government used to
discriminate against black citizens I
have a plan to deal with the maternal
health crisis in this country that black
women are dying at three and four times
the rate of white women it's time for
some accountability in this system
okay so Elizabeth Warren is not going to
win the nomination okay she's just not
going to she does not have the appeal to
black voters that Kamala Harris does and
it's going to be a serious problem for
oh it's gonna be a serious problem for
Elizabeth Warren it doesn't have the
same pitch she can't do the pandering
lying routine the Carmel Harris did she
can't say I'm in the line of various
black heroes Rosa Parks in Maya Angelou
she can't do that so instead it's I have
a plan here's a bunch of stuff I'm going
to give you fail fail okay and then
there is Bernie Sanders and Sanders at
least knows where he stands Bernie
Sanders isn't trying to make a pitch for
black voters basically at all Bernie
Sanders is just going to be as socialist
as he wants to be and then hope that he
has enough white support to outpace to
outpace Bernie Sanders and and khamel
Harris he basically hopes that they
fight for black support and that he kind
of soars over the top with his solid
base of white support he is fighting
Elizabeth Warren for that base right now
here's Bernie Sanders explaining that
every teacher should own at least sixty
thousand dollars but yeah let's talk
about that go bunny every teacher in
America should earn at least sixty
thousand dollars a year okay so I have a
question why 60,000 why not 600,000
aren't teachers the greatest among us
don't teachers deserve more than that
why 60,000 dollars a year
now I'm because we can't afford it right
I mean that's the idea we can't afford
it but what makes you think that we can
afford 60,000 dollars a year for a
teacher wouldn't the market decide what
exactly that bears the truth is that if
we didn't have
unions in America's public schools that
were creating terrible contracts for
students and school districts I'm sure
there would be teachers paid $100,000 a
year $150,000 a year in other words
performance would decide how you get
paid in the public schools as opposed to
tenure you wouldn't be the oldest
teacher at the school and therefore you
get paid the most you wouldn't be at the
best school and therefore get paid the
most you would presumably be at some of
the worst schools and get paid more
because it's a harder job wouldn't that
be the way to do it but I do love it
when socialists like Bernie Sanders
simply throw out prices as though he
knows what the hell he's talking about
one of the the great sort of vanities of
the socialist project is saying that the
supply-demand profit system is a bad way
of determining value and then using the
values created by that profit system by
that supply and demand system and using
it as the basis for your demands so what
I mean is how does Bernie Sanders know
what the price of a teacher should be if
I just said to you in a vacuum what's
the price of a teacher you can't look at
any of the prices you don't know what
anyone is paid you'd have no idea right
it's like me saying what's the price of
a blue you wouldn't know because there's
no such things about except for
everything that a OS he says but there
if I if I named a product that does not
exist you can't tell me the price of it
because you have no basis for comparison
when Bernie Sanders says a teacher
should be paid sixty thousand dollars a
year
the only reason he knows to say that is
because teachers are getting paid
somewhere in the neighborhood of $60,000
a year fifty thousand or forty five
thousand the point is that as part of a
supply and demand system he completely
rejects in a profit based system he
completely rejects so he's just pulling
numbers out of thin air and then saying
it's not fair if the market doesn't meet
his bizarre notion of what people should
be paid even though he's never run a
taco stand Bernie Sanders so but at
least he's got his pitch so right now as
Joe Biden fades is pretty obvious that
his support is bleeding over to Kamala
Harris not to Elizabeth Warren and not
really to Bernie Sanders so you have to
put Camille Harris as the odds-on
favorite to win the nomination as
cynical and terrible as that is right
now as cynical and it's really really
cynical incredibly cynical and meanwhile
in the Republican Party there's a bit of
chaos over the last week while I was
away just in a match of the Justin Amash
I think it is pronounced the the mosh
thank you the libertarian slash
Republican
as person he's not a Republican anymore
Congress person from Michigan we've had
him on the radio show before I actually
like a lot of what Justin Amash has to
say but he said he's leaving the
Republican Party now supposedly
originally he was leaving because he was
just so disgusted with their treatment
of President Trump he did say over the
weekend he would leave the GOP even if
Trump weren't president which is a
bizarre statement for somebody who was
elected as a Republican here is Amash do
you think you would be leaving the
Republican Party if Donald Trump were
not president yes I do and I've had
concerns with the Republican Party for
several years I've had concerns of the
party system generally when I first got
to Congress I thought I could change
things from the inside but as I've spent
time there I've seen that not only me I
don't think there is anyone in there who
can change the system it's pretty rigid
it's top-down it comes down from
leadership to the bottom and over the
years it's gotten more rigid now it's
hilarious about this is the damash
leaving the Republican Party and
declaring himself independent Donald
Trump is mad about this he's tweeting
about how bad this is if a mush does
leave and he's left if he decides to run
for the Libertarian Party nomination
which is quite likely at this point if
he runs for the Libertarian Party
nomination and runs as a libertarian the
vast majority of votes he's going to
draw are not going to be drawn from the
Republican Party Trump's level of
popularity among Republicans is very
high in fact Amash could be one of the
best things that happens to Donald Trump
in the 2020 election because from has
the luck of the devil and the fact is
that Amash could draw more votes from
Democrats in Michigan then he draws from
Republicans in Michigan leading
President Trump to win Michigan again so
maybe this all ends up as a benefit for
president Trump in the end anyway okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like over the holiday weekend I got to
read rich cones new book rich cone is
one of my favorite authors he's written
about everything from the 1985 Chicago
Bears to Jewish gangsters cause he has a
book called tough Jews about Jewish
gangsters from New York really terrific
writer has a new piece of pop history
called the last pirate of New York a
ghost ship a killer and the birth of a
gangster nation all about the last
pirate hanged in the United States and
the book is really fun it's it's a quick
breezy read riches
terrific writer so go check it out the
last pirate of New York and go ship a
killer and the birth of a gangster
nation I recommended it to Politico as
well
rich is incredibly talented and and I
really enjoy his stuff so that is
definitely worth the summer read okay
now it is time for a bevy of things that
I hate cells away for a week guys oh man
so many things that I hate today yeah
you're waiting for the hate and so here
it comes okay let's begin
with this piece of idiocy so there's an
article in The New York Times called do
Americans need air conditioning yes yes
Americans need air conditioning it is
one of the more irritating aspects of
modern life that all the benefits of
modern life that we enjoy we now get to
sit back and say you know what maybe we
don't need those benefits anymore let's
go back to the old ways when we didn't
have air conditioning and tens of
thousands of people died of heatstroke
every year I remember a few years back
it's like 2005 I believe there's a heat
wave in France and there wasn't enough
air conditioning in France and 10,000
elderly people died in France because of
the heat wave in France it turns out
that the earth is trying to kill you and
one of the ways that you defend yourself
from the earth is to build a shelter and
within that shelter to have some climate
control in fact one of the leading
causes of the rise in productivity in
the American South in the 20th century
was the advent of air conditioning
because it turned out it was very
difficult to work in hot humid sticky
conditions and once air conditioning
became prevalent in the American South
it allowed people to work for longer
hours it allowed people to work at their
desks without falling apart climate has
an impact on humid but human behavior
there's a woman named Taylor Lorenz who
tweeted out over the weekend that air
conditioning was sexist and bigoted
because men keep the thermostat too low
and that she gets sick every time the
a/c is on okay first of all a couple
things one air conditioning does not
make you sick climate does not make you
sick
hey germs make you sick you don't get
sick if it's too cold outside you don't
get sick if it's too warm outside that's
just people miss attributing the nature
of illness also air conditioning has
better the lives of hundreds of millions
of people and saved tens of thousands of
lives nonetheless the New York Times
from it's air-conditioned offices in New
York has a piece called do Americans
need air conditioning summers great
indoor temperature debate rages on and
Green writing modernity was born 116
years 11 months two weeks in two days
ago at a printing plant in the East
Williamsburg section of Brooklyn when a
junior engineer named Willis carrier
devised a contraption that blew air over
water filled pipes to dry out the
humidity that was gumming up the pages
of a humor magazine called judge and in
that moment well within a few decades
entire industries and geographies were
transformed new technologies made
possible including terribly the internet
without cooling there would be no server
farms nearly 90% of American households
now have some form of air-conditioning
more than any other country in the world
except Japan though that will change as
global warming alters more temperate
zones and swelling populations and
rising incomes in hot zones mean the
folks there will clamor for AEC - on an
overheated planet air-conditioning
becomes more and more desirable solving
in the short term the problem it helped
create it is another paradox that even
as architects and engineers are making
ever more efficient buildings to meet
energy standards set by cities like New
York where a new law says that buildings
over 25,000 square feet must reduce
their carbon emissions by 80% by 2050 we
are still freezing in our offices and
fighting with our partners over whether
to turn on the friedrich my god i mean
the amount of fighting and brutality
okay quick rule i know there are a lot
of women who complain that men keep the
office temperature too low i have this
problem in my home and night my wife
wants the temperature in the house
higher and i want the temperature in the
house lower there's a difference the
difference is that I cannot strip down
to my t-shirt at the office if I am in
an office where people were suits you
can put on a sweater so if it's going if
we're intruding too hot and too cold too
cold is the proper solution that is not
sexist that is basic logic unless you
want men stripping down to their under
rules which presumably you don't want in
an office environment parts of Germany
and France were recently steaming
through record temperatures during last
week's heatwave police officers in Paris
use tear gas on climate change
protesters while I was southbound on
Amtrak's Northeast Regional shivering in
the quiet car rug DUP in a scarf jacket
long pants and boots so were my fellow
travelers like Solange singer a 41 year
old fashion stylist muffled in similar
gear with a red wool scarf laid out in
her lap like a blanket the conductor
seemed puzzled when I asked him what
temperature the thermostat was set to
there is no thermostat he said it's
either off or on fire as the saying goes
made us human does the air-conditioning
make us less so
well it makes you less dead it makes you
less dead it turns out lack of air
conditioning kills people but people are
very upset about this now so the New
York Times has the luxury
environmentalism and worries about the
thermostat these are luxuries of a first
world nation mark Feeny a culture critic
at the Boston Globe which is a hell of a
hell of a career he says think about
that term air-conditioning do you want
to condition your air yes yes I do
because you know what I don't want to do
I live in SoCal I remember a few years
back the transformer blew I'm the street
where my parents live it was on a
Saturday so we couldn't even get in the
car I was a Shabbat we couldn't even get
in the car and drive to a place that was
air-conditioned it was 105 degrees in
the valley that day it was hellish it
was hellish you know it would have been
great a functional air-conditioner do
you want to condition your air yes you
want to condition your air people your
skin maybe or your hair I'm a vegetarian
but I didn't become one for any specific
reason it just happened but there are
all sorts of good expat s posts ex post
facto reasons for not eating meat
same with AC if you modify your actions
it's good for the planet it's good for
everyone also I'm the lapsed Catholic
and I'm Irish so I need a certain degree
of self-imposed suffering in my life and
I guess this qualified well that's that
that's really what is going on here
truthfully that's a throwaway line it's
a joke I understand it is also what's
going on here there's a new secular
religion of environmentalism where you
are supposed to sacrifice to the great
god of the climate by not having
air-conditioning in your home good luck
with that
you want it it's all yours because guess
what no one else is going along with you
no one else is going along with you that
we should get rid of air conditioning
it's this this is all so stupid and so
arrogant but I guess everything and
we're gonna make everything that is
non-controversial something
controversial this is what happened
while I was gone right we decided that
we were gonna turn the Betsy Ross flag
controversial for no reason
Betsy Ross was a Quaker abolitionist she
was an anti-slavery activist but
apparently the Betsy Ross flag became
deeply controversial because a failed
NFL quarterback and a person whose
record on politics is worse than his
record in the National Football League
that guy says he has a problem with the
Betsy Ross flag and so it becomes a
national controversy so now we're gonna
have discussions over air conditioning
all I can say is lady
you go first if you want to get rid of
air conditioning you can swelter it out
in 85 degree humidity in New York City
during the summer enjoy yourself that is
all you but we're gonna make everything
controversial there's a problem in our
country and the problem is that things
are so good and we are so angry that we
are now looking at stupid things to be
angry about Jonah Goldberg had a column
over the weekend where he basically said
America has autoimmune disease that
there not enough pathogens in the body
politic for us to attack so we are
creating pathogens out of healthy organs
just to attack so we're willing to
attack air conditioning or we're going
to attack
the Betsy Ross flag and that was what
happened while I was gone now listen
Nike can do whatever it wants it's a
private corporation but that said it's
really dumb in the long term now it's
smart short term Nike actually gained
stock share the share price after they
made this decision about getting rid of
the sneakers with the Betsy Ross flag
and there's a reason for that
the reason for that is because by
Statistics black folks in America are
more sympathetic to Colin Kaepernick's
wild and extreme political claims and
they also happen to buy more shoes the
stock prices went up for Nike this has
been true since they signed Colin
Kaepernick
that's why Nikes doing what they're
doing if you think that they sort of
mistaked their way into this that is not
true they did this on purpose they
decided to get woke because they wanted
to make money this is why corporations
do this sort of stuff during Gay Pride
Month they decide they're all going to
virtue signal because they understand
that the people who are attracted to
their brand by the virtue signaling
outnumber the people who are alienated
from their brand by the virtue signaling
and they figure that there's no other
place to go what are you gonna stop
going to target because they have a
couple of displays for Gay Pride Month
or something but if you're gay or if
you're very sympathetic to Gay Pride
Month then you're more likely to feel
good about shopping at Target because
their virtue is signaling to you Nike
does the same thing but the whole goal
here is to make things controversial
that are really uncontroversial this is
the routine and speaking of that they
decided over the weekend that they were
gonna make controversial having like a
tank at a July 4th parade in Washington
DC couple of things thanks for kind of
cool I understand you hate Trump and
everything but tanks I'm pretty cool and
we have Blue Angels flyovers all the
time it's July 4th events you know it's
more power
powerful than a tank in today's day and
age a self bomber there are lots of
things more powerful than a tank if you
had to face the two up against each
other and you were just showing powerful
military weaponry we showed those
military weapons on a fairly routine
basis weren't marching nuclear missiles
through the streets of Washington DC
nonetheless we decided to make this
controversial - here's a CNN anchor
worrying that trumps July 4th speech was
too militaristic because he had the
temerity to talk about how great the
American military was it sounded very
very different from the typical Trump
rallies that are often broadcast on
cable news but that showcase of the
military hardware that were showing
pictures of here some would say it over
emphasized America's military might and
it under played the American values that
have been used to justify the use of
force yeah and so that is something that
the president will be criticized on oh
is that something he will be criticized
on or is that something you're
criticizing him on right now like this
very instant everything becomes
controversial in a nation where a bunch
of stuff shouldn't be controversial
another example apparently in the week
that I was gone people decided that
apparently leaves a vast swath of
Americans who are deeply profoundly
upset that Disney has cast a black
actress to play Ariel in the new
live-action Disney remake of the Little
Mermaid first of all this is better
evidence to me this whole story is
better evidence to me that Disney has no
new ideas that they keep remaking all of
their old movies scene for scene that's
the only evidence I see but they decided
that they were going to like everyone in
the media decided it was a massive issue
that Americans were out in the streets
protesting because Ariel who is white
and redheaded in the animated film will
now be black and redheaded in the non
animated film there was not a single
blue checkmark person on Twitter who
commented about this because no one
actually cares about this stuff no one
seriously cares about this stuff
there may be a species a fan person
fangirls really cuz that's really who
likes the Little Mermaid who want the
Little Mermaid to look like she looked
in the animated flick which is not
racist by the way that is just I grew up
with a particular image of the Little
Mermaid and all the other animated films
reflect that image right the new Mulan
live-action film has a person who looks
like Mulan in the animated film it's not
racist to say what if the person
in the live film looked like the person
in the animated film no matter how they
look right they're not gonna cast Tiana
is white presumably when they remake The
Princess and the Frog but apparently
there was like there are two people on
Twitter who are like we cannot have a
black Ariel no no like the number of
people this is what we call nut picking
okay nut picking is what you do online
when you try to find somebody with a
crazy opinion specifically so that you
can make them the sort of advocate for
the entire other side of the aisle no
one cared it trended on Twitter anyway
it trended on Twitter anyway so we're
gonna make everything controversial
everything is gonna be controversial
because what we're bored because we're
too prosperous air-conditioning is
controversial
the Betsy Ross flag which flew at Barack
Obama's inauguration is apparently now
controversial and symbolizes slavery
even though it was Union troops fighting
slavery who carried that into battle
that's the that's controversial black
aerial is controversial
everything is controversial tanks at
parades for July 4th that's common like
everything is controversial now how
about this how about we all calm down
how about we all recognize that half the
stuff we think is controversial no one
cares about I don't think that's going
to happen though and that's why I think
Joe Biden is in trouble in this race
because Joe Biden is running a back to
normalcy campaign at a time where his
party does not want to return to
normalcy and where it's unclear that the
American people will want to return to
normalcy for all the talk about the
American people being deeply
dispossessed by Donald Trump's odd net
oddities the truth is that the American
people might just be pissed off for a
variety of reasons including I think a
sort of spiritual emptying out of all
the things that used to unify us and so
now we're just creating random
controversies to attack each other over
that was the story of the last week as I
see it from afar anyway all right so
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content plus we'll
be back here tomorrow welcome back i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily weiter
2019 hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know that
Donald Trump he may not be the nicest
guy in the world but through his
belligerence and his indifference to the
brutal slanders of the Democrat media
complex he has made a place for his
followers the deplorable z-- to reinvent
American patriotism it's a beautiful
thing to see and the left reaction is as
ugly as you can imagine we'll talk about
it on the Andrew Klavan show I'm Andrew
Clavin